สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าคะวัน
นี้เราเจอกันวันอะไรคะวันนี้เราเจอกันวัน
พฤหัสบดีค่ะวัน
พฤหัสวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
3 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
พฤศจิกายน
หืปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีคศ
2022 ค่ะโอเคตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูป๊า
ตอนนี้เวลา 14
น
่า 2  30  33 นาทีค่ะ 33 นาทีแล้ว 3 นาที
แล้วโอเคเป็นยังไงบ้างครูเรียมสบายดีมย
โอเคมสบายดีค่ะครููฟ้าแต่รู้สึกว่าเหมือน
แบบสายตาจะ
แบบสายตาจะแบบแย่ลงนิดนึงสายตาแย่ลงเหรอ
คะครูเรียมครูเรียมทำอะไรมาครูเรียมดู
ทีวีเยอะหรอหรือว่าดูโทรศัพท์เยอะๆ
อหน่าจะแบบดู
โทรศัพท์ดูโทรศัพท์เยอะๆดูโทรศัพท์นานๆ
แล้วสายตาก็แย่ลงสายตาแย่ลงใช่ไม่ได้แล้ว
ครูเรียมทำยังไงดีคะครูฟ้าครูเรียมต้อง
กินวิตามินมั้ยกินวิตามินด้วยนะคะครู
เรียมอาจจะต้องกินวิตวิตามินด้วยเพื่อ
ช่วยสายตาใช่ไหมแล้วครูเรียมก็ต้องไปตัด
แว่นอ๋อแว่นตาเหมือนที่ครูฟ้าใส่หรอใช่
ค่ะครูฟ้าใส่แว่นตาเห็นไมมครูเรียมต้อง
ใส่แว่นตานะคะอือครูฟ้าใส่ตา
สั้นหรือสายตายาวสายตาสายตาสั้นว่าวสายตา
สั้นนะคะก็เลยต้องใส่แว่นอืออของคุฟ้า
สั้นเท่าไหร่โอของครูฟ้าน่าจะสั้น
ประมาณ 5  600 แล้วมั้ง
6 หหเยอะนะแต่ว่าเด็กๆเนาะเด็กๆหลายๆคน
ก็จะสายตาสั้นอืมองเห็นต้องมองแบบนี้ใช่
มยครูฟ้าถ้าครูฟ้าถอดแว่นตาออกครูฟ้าถอด
ตรงนี้ครูฟ้ามองเห็น
มยเห็นค่ะตรงนี้ครูฟ้ามองเห็นนะแต่เกออก
ไปอย่างงี้
ล่ะมองไม่เห็นเนี่ยเก็จะมองไม่เห็นอออื
มองไม่เห็นตรงนี้มองเห็นก็จะเรียกว่าสาย
ตาสั้นใช่อ๋อเนี่ยเพราว่าสายตาสั้นคิดว่า
เด็กหลายๆคนนะอายุแบบ 10 ขวบ 12 ขวบหรือ
ว่ามากกว่านั้นก็จะแบบสายตาสั้นเยอะมากๆ
อืๆอือๆสำหรับคนที่แบบอายุเยอะๆคนที่แบบ
อายุ 80
ปีอายุ 90 ปีก็มีหลายคนนะที่สายตายาวแล้ว
ก็ต้องใส่แว่นใช่มั้ยใช่ก็ต้องใส่แว่นตาอ
ไม่อย่างงั้นเวลาอ่านหนังสือก็ต้อง
แบบไกลไกลอืใชดูใกล้ๆเนี่ยมองไม่เห็น
ใช่แล้วค่ะครูเรียมเห็นไหมเหมือนเรื่อง
ที่เรียมจะเล่าวันนี้เลยค่ะครูฟ้าครู
เรียมมีเรื่องที่จะเล่าในวัน
นี้
ใช่เป็นเรื่องของลิงตัว
นึงลิงลิงเป็นลิงแล้วเกี่ยวอะไรกับสายตา
สั้นสายตายาวพกูเรียมลิงเนี่ยนะคะคิงคอง
กอริลล่า
ลิงใช่เพราะว่าลิงตัวนี้แก่แล้วลิงตัวนี้
มีอายุเยอะมากๆเดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะขหา
อุ๊ยลิงเหรอคะหูเหลี่ยมลิงแก่อันนี้ลิง
อันนี้ลิงอันนี้ลิงแต่ว่าลิงแก่เป็นยังไง
แก่เป็นงี้มั้โอ้แก่เออแก่จริงหรรือ
เปล่าอันนี้แก่มยลิงแก่นะคะลิงแก่ลิงแก่
ใช่ถ้าเกิดลิง 1 ปีลิง 1 ปี 2 ปีเนี่ยใช่
ลิงแก่มั้ยไม่แก่หรอก 1 ปี 2 ปีแต่ลิงแก่
อายุเท่าไหร่อ่ะไม่รู้นะลิงแก่เรียมคิด
ว่าประมาณแบบ 40 ปีอ 50
ปีจะเป็นลิงแก่อืๆๆอืแต่ 1 ปี 2 ปีไม่แก่
ลิงแก่เป็นเรื่องของลิงแก่ใช่มั้ยคะครู
เรียมใช่ค่ะลิงแก่ที่พอเวลามีอายุมากขึ้น
ลิงแก่มากขึ้นสายตาลิงก็จะแย่ลง
อืเอ๊ะสายตาลิงแย่ลงแล้วลิงต้องใส่แว่นมย
ลิงก็คิดนะคิดว่าเอ๊หรือว่าต้องใส่แว่น
เพราะว่าลิงเคยได้ยินเคยได้ยินคนอเหมือน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยคนเหมือนภูเเหลียมเคยได้ยินคน
คุยกันว่าสายตาไม่ดีก็ใส่แว่นใช่สายตาไม่
ดีต้องใส่แว่นแล้วลิงสายตาดีมยมันต้องใส่
แว่นหรือเปล่านี่เห็นมั้ยก็บอกอโอเคลิง
สายตาไม่ดีลิงต้องใส่แว่น
อืเว่นลิงแบบฉลาดมาก
อ่าไอคิวดีมากมากอืแล้วลิงก็เลยต้องไปหา
แว่นมาใส่ค่ะใช่แล้วลิงก็เลยเข้าไปในหมู่
บ้านหมู่บ้านที่มี
บ้านบ้านบ้านบ้านรวมกันเป็นหมู่บ้านก็ไป
ทำอะไรในหมู่บ้านล่ะครูเรียมลิงก็เข้าไป
ขโมยแว่น
ตาขโมยแว่นตาเลยหรอลิงไม่ซื้อลิงไม่ไปตัด
แว่นตาไปตัดแว่นก็คือต้องไปเช็คใช่มั้ยคะ
แล้วก็ทำแว่นขึ้นมาใช่แต่ไปขโมยไปขโมยอื
ก็แบบเดินๆดิเข้าไปไม่ให้ใครเห็น
นะไม่ให้ใครเห็นด้วย
โอ้โหแล้วก็ไปขโมยแว่นตาไปขโมยแว่น
ตานิสัยไม่ดีเลยนะคะลิงตัวนี้เอ้าลิงไม่
มีเงินอือ๋อใช่แต่ลิงจะไปตัดแว่นไม่ได้
เพราะว่าลิงไม่มีเงินใช่ๆอนั่นแหละลิงก็
เลยไปขโมยแว่นตามา
อืแล้วพอกลับมาถึงป่าออยู่ไหนปากเป็นยัง
ไงเป็นยังไงคะลิงก็หุ้ยลิงจะใส่แว่นตาค่ะ
ลิงจะใส่แว่นตาที่ขโมยมาใช่ใช่ลิงก็เลย
เอาแว่นตามาใส่ที่หัว
อืเอาแว่นตาเลยมาใส่ทำไมลิงไม่เอาแว่นตา
มาใส่ที่ตาคะกครูเลียมลิงไม่รู้ลิงไม่รู้
ว่าเอาใส่ที่ไหนลิงก็คิดว่าออเอาแว่นตา
ใส่หัวแล้วลิงก็พูดบอกว่าก็มองมองไม่เห็น
มองไม่เห็นลิงเนี่ยตาไม่ดีใช่มยก็เอาไป
ขโมยแว่นตาแล้วเอามาใส่ไว้ที่หัวแล้วก็
พูดว่าเฮ้ยทำไมใส่แว่นตาแล้วยังมองไม่
เห็นเอ้อใช่แล้วทีนี้ลิงก็เลยเปลี่ยนลิง
ก็เลยแบบ
โอเคเดี๋ยวเอาแว่นตามาใส่ที่หางอเอาตามา
ใส่ที่หางใช่
แล้วเป็นยังไงบ้างคะเอาแว่นตาใส่ที่หาง
ได้มั้ยแว่นตาแว่นตานะไม่ดีไม่
ดีใส่แว่นตาแล้วก็มองมองไม่เห็น
อืโธ่เอ๊ยแว่นตาไม่ดีใส่แว่นตาแล้วก็ยัง
มองไม่เห็นทำยังไงล่ะลิงก็เลยคิดเอ๊จะเอา
แว่นตาไปใส่ตรงไหนนะ
เอาแว่นตาใแล้วลิงทำยังไงต่อคะครูเรียม
เอาแว่นตาใส่ที่หางก็ยังมองไม่
เห็นใช่ลิงก็เลยเอาแว่นตามาใส่ที่
ขาเอาแว่นตาใส่ที่ขาใช่เป็นไงคะครูฟ้าครู
ฟ้าเคยเอาแว่นตาไปใส่ที่ขามก็เคยนะว่าเอา
แว่นตาวางไว้ที่ขาเนี่ยแหละค่ะอก็ไม่ได้
อะไรนะคะนเรมองไม่เห็นเลยค่ะครูเลียมเอา
แวนตาใสไว้ที่ขาก็ยังมองไม่เห็นทำไม
เนี่ยเหมือนลิงตัวนี้เลยเอาแว่นตาใส่ที่
ขาก็มองไม่เห็นอืทำยังไงหนลิงก็บอกว่าอ้อ
แว่นตาไม่
ดีตาไม่
ดีใช่แล้วลิงทำยังไงต่อลิงก็เปลี่ยน
เปลี่ยนไปใส่ที่
แขนก็มองไม่เห็นเออไปใส่ที่ต่าง
ๆทั่วร่างกายก็ยังมองไม่เห็นอืริงก็ยัง
บอกว่ามองไม่เห็นมองไม่เห็น
ทำไมทำไมคนน่ะคนหลายๆคนบอกว่าใส่แว่นตา
แล้วจะมองเห็นดีมากขึ้น
เอ้าลิงเนี่ยแปลว่าลิงเนี่ยเคยได้ยินใช่
มยว่าคนคุยคุยกันอืเกี่ยวกับแว่นตาคนคุย
กันว่าใส่แว่นตาแล้วดีใส่แว่นตาแล้วจะมอง
เห็นแต่ลิงเนี่ยไม่เคยเห็นคนใส่แว่นตาใช่
มยลิงก็เลยไม่รู้ว่าต้องใส่แว่นที่
ไหนใช่ไม่เคยเห็นนั่นแหละลิงก็เลยคิดว่า
คนอื่นเ่ะพูดโกหกพูดไม่จริงไม่จริงอือๆๆ
อืโธ่เอ๋ยนะคะลิงทำยังไงล่ะคะทีนี้ใส่
แว่นตาก็ไม่ได้ลิงก็ใส่แว่นตาไม่ได้ค่ะ
ลิงก็เลยแบบทำลายแว่น
ตาเอามือ
ทุบเอามือทุบแว่นแว่นก็หักสิคะแบบนี้ใช่
แว่นก็หักเพราะว่าลิงก็คิดว่าแว่นไม่ดี
แว่นไม่ได้ช่วยให้ลิงมองเห็นดีขึ้นลิงก็
แบบ
พุบแว่นก็พังแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าไปขโมยแว่นคน
อื่นมาและใช้ไม่เป็นเราพูดว่าใช้ไม่เป็น
นะคะก็คือลิงเนี่ยใช้ไม่เป็นเพราะว่าไม่
รู้จะใช้แว่นยังไงไม่รู้จะใส่แว่นไว้ที่
ไหนก็เลยใส่ที่หัวที่แขนที่ขาเราบอกว่า
ใช้ไม่เป็นไปขโมยแว่นมาแล้วใช้ไม่เป็นอื
ก็ยังทำลายแว่นทิ้ง
อีกใสัไม่ดีเลยทำไมไม่เอาไปคืนไม่อืเออ
ไม่คืนแล้วค่ะตั้งแต่ขโมยมาก็นิสัยไม่ดี
แล้วค่ะครูปาอืมใช่ค่ะแบบไม่ไหวเลยนะคะ
ลิงตัวนี้นะคะแต่ว่าเรื่องนี้ก็สอนนะสอน
ให้เรารู้ว่าบางอย่างที่มันมีค่ามันมี
ประโยชน์ที่อยู่กับคนที่ใช้ไม่เป็นน่ะ
อืก็ไม่ได้ช่วยอะไรเลย
ใช่ของบางอย่างที่เรารู้สึกว่ามันมี
ประโยชน์มากๆโอ้ยทำไมของอนี้มีประโยชน์
จังนะคะแต่มันนันไปอยู่กับคนที่ไม่เข้าใจ
ประโยชน์ของมันไปอยู่กับคนที่ใช้ประโยชน์
ไม่เป็นใช้ไม่
เป็นใช่ของมันก็จะราคา 0 บาทเลยใช่มยใช่
เหมือนแบบโทรศัพท์อ่ะโทรศัพท์ที่ครูฟ้า
ซื้อมาแบบแพงมากแบบ 56,000
,000 แล้วก็เอามาให้เอาไปให้คนคนนึงเอา
ไปให้ยายคนนึงที่
อายุ 80 อื 80 ปีอือแล้วยายก็เลยบอก
ว่าเมื่อไหร่เมื่อไหร่ที่แบบลูกๆหลานๆโทร
มาก็จะกดปุ่มนี้นะโอเคแล้วยายก็จะพูดแบบ
นี้ใช่
มั้ยแต่ว่ามันราคามันแพงมากอ่ะครูฟ้าออๆๆ
ไปอยู่กับคนที่ใช้ไม่เป็นอือๆเออใช้
ประโยชน์ไม่ได้ใช่ค่ะเออน่าเสียดายมากลก็
น่าเสียดายมากเห็นมั้ยโอนิทานเรื่องนี้
มันสอนเหมือนกันนะจริงๆเนี่ยประเทศไทย
เนี่ยมันจะ
มีมันจะมีเค้าเรียกว่าคำพูดอยู่อย่างนึง
นะคะนักเรียนเป็นเหมือนสำนวนใช่่มยมันจะ
มีคำพูดว่าหัวล้านได้หวี
อ๋อเรียนเคยได้ยินมั้ย
หัวร้านได้หวีนะคะหัว้านหัวร้านได้หวี
เป็นแบบนี้ใช่มยครูฟ้าหัวร้านเนี่ยก็คือ
คนที่ไม่มีผมนะนักเรียนอันนี้ไม่ใช่บูลี่
หรืออะไรแต่มันเป็นคำพูดของแบบคนไทยนะ
เป็นสำนวนนะคะบอกว่าหัวล้านได้หวีก็คือคน
หัวล้านคนที่ไม่มีผมเนี่ยใช่
มยได้หวี
มา
อืมไนคูเรียมวาดหวีนะคะได้หวีมาเอาหวีมา
หวีผมเแต่คนหัวร้านไม่มีผมนะคนหัวร้านไม่
มีผมเขาก็ได้หวีมาเคก็ต้องเก็ไม่ได้ใช้
หวีใช่ไหมมเอามาทำอะไรก็ไม่ได้ทำอะไรเลย
นะคะหวีที่ได้มา
ก็ใช้ไม่ได้อือืก็หมายถึงคนที่เาไม่ได้
ใช้ประโยชน์เไม่ได้ใช้อะไรแล้วได้สิ่งของ
ของอันนั้นมามันก็จะกลายเป็นว่าเาไม่ได้
ใช้มันอยู่ดีอืหัวร้านได้หวีลิงได้แว่น
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยอืออไก่ได้พลอยไก่ได้พลอย
หรอเหมือนกันหรอเพชรพลอยที่แบบเป็นของที่
แบบถ้าเอาไปขายนะจะได้เงินเยอะมากใช่แต่
เวลาที่ไก่แบบกินข้าวใช่มยไก่กุ๊กๆกิน
ข้าวเค้าจะก็จะเอาขา 2 ข้างเขี่ยอือมวาด
รูปให้ดูวาดรูปไก่ได้ค่ะ
รมเหมือนไก่มอ่ะคุณ
ป๊าเหมือนอยู่นะเหมือนไก่
อ่าเหมือนไก่แล้วมีงอนม
อ่าไก่เค้าก็จะเอาเท้าใช่มยเอาเท้าหรือ
เอาขาเขี่ยเขี่
อือเขี่ยแล้วถ้าเกิดมันเจอพลอยหรือว่าเจอ
เพชรตรงเนี้ยครูฟ้า
อืเจอเพชรที่แพงมากๆนะคะนักเรียนอราคาแพง
มากๆเพชรน่ะนักเรียนเอาไปทำแหวนใช่มั้ย
ใช่เอาไปทำแหวนแต่ถ้าเกิดไก่เห็นเพชรเห็น
พลอยไก่ก็จะเขี่ทิ้งนะครูฟ้าอืมเพราะว่า
ไก่เนี่ยไม่รู้ว่าเพชรเนี่ยมีราคาแพงอมัน
กินไม่ได้ไงใช่แค่ไก่รู้ว่าเออเพชรน่ะ
เพชรหรือพลอยเนี่ยกินไม่ได้เขี่ยทิ้งอือื
แต่ว่ามันก็จะมีอะไรที่ไม่เหมือนกันนิด
หน่อยนะกับเรื่องที่เรียมเล่าไปอืคือลิง
น่ะรู้รู้ว่าแว่นตาเนี่ยช่วยให้เค้าสายตา
ดีขึ้นได้ใช่ๆเค้ารู้ไงแต่เาใช้ไม่เป็น
ใช่มอือแล้วเคก็อยากดแต่เขใช้ไม่เป็น
อืแค่นั้นเองเออเนาะใช่อันนี้ถามว่าแว่น
เนี่ยมันมีประโยชน์กับลิงมยแว่นก็มี
ประโยชน์กับลิงนะคะแต่ลิงไม่รู้ว่าใช้ยัง
ไงทำยังไงใช้ไม่เป็นนิดหน่อยเอออืใช่ค่ะค
เหลี่ยมใช่ใช่เป็นแบบนั้นเลยแล้วก็หูฟ้า
ก็ลองดูซิว่าเออในชีวิตเราเนี่ยมีใครบ้าง
น้าที่มีของดีๆอยู่แต่ว่าใช้ไม่เป็นเดมก็
คิดนะว่าเอ๊ะมีใครบ้างน้าที่มีของดีๆอยู่
แต่ใช้ไม่เป็นูเรียมมีมั้ยก็มีนะค้ามี
อะไรหรอก็มีนะเงินมงคะเงินหรอจริงหรอครู
ฟ้าใช้เงินไม่เป็นหรอเพราะครูฟ้าอยากได้
อะไรครูฟ้าก็ซื้อไงอยากได้แล้วก็ซื้ออยาก
ได้แล้วก็ซื้อเราบอกใช้เงินไม่เป็นใช่ม
เราไม่เก็บเงินน่ะอ๋อใช้เงินไม่เป็นแบบ
ไม่ไม่เอาไปซื้อของได้เงินกลับมาอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยใช่ใช้เงินไม่เป็นนะคะเออเออ
เหมือนกันเลยเหมือนกันนะเงกับเรื่องนี้
รู้นะรู้ว่าเงินเนี่ยถ้าเกิดมีก็บดีๆๆแต่
ว่าก็ใช้ใช้ออกไปเรื่อยๆแบบที่ไม่ได้คิด
ว่ามันจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นใช่มอืใช่เค้าก็
เรียกใช้เงินไม่เป็นก็เลยบอกว่าตัวเนี้ก็
ใช้แว่นไม่เป็นใช่ๆค่ะนิทานเรื่องนี้ก็
เลยบอกว่า
อ่าของที่มีประโยชน์อยู่กับคนที่มี
ประโยชน์ก็จะดีขึ้นของที่มีประโยชน์อยู่
กับคนที่ไม่รู้วิธีใช้มันก็ไม่มันก็ไม่มี
ประโยชน์อะไรนะคะนักเรียนอันนี้ก็เป็น
สตอรี่วันนี้คิดว่าน่าจะหมดเวลาแล้วมยออๆ
ใช่ใช่หมดเวลาละเดี๋ยวแบบนักเรียนจะรู้
สึกงงเข้าไปใหญ่ว่าสึกงงมากไปกว่านี้
เพราะฉะนั้นครูฟ้าครูเรียมก็ต้องไปก่อนนะ
คะนักเรียนไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่
วีีดีโอหน้าเนาะใช่แล้วเจอกันใหม่นะคะครู
ฟ้าเจอกันใหม่นะคะนักเรียนได้ค่ะบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะบบสวัสดีค่ะตกลงมันคืออะไรอ่ะ
ครูฟ้ามีไม่
ใช้ไม่รู้ก็มีของดีๆไงแต่แบบไม่ได้ใช้ใช้
ไม่
เป็นไปดี
กว่าอ